*siren sound*
Call the police.....
A new demo is out..
Today!!
This just came out!!
Its so fresh that....
Yeah Gotta call the co- , Gotta call the poli-
*demon*
Alright....
So.....
Resident Evil 7
Teaser came out!!
I don't know ...
But i think they are trying to pull a PT here!
If you are not familiar
PT was a horror game that came out last year!
It's officially the most dowloaded demo of all time...
Not sure if that's true, but i think that's what- that-
What's that Matthew Mcconaughey ,
It's confirming me those numbers right now....
Those numbers are confirmed
So...
Obviously.....
How is Resident Evil 7 gonna promote themselves
There gonna try to do the same thing!!
There gonna try and drop a demo....
Let's check it out,
Is it as good as PT?
Highly doubt it
*laughs*
Resident Evil is really a franchise that has gone down hill!!
Since number 4 .......
5 was shit!
6 was garbage...
7...
Will they bring it back?
I don't know...
Let's find out!
Yeah they are definitely Pcing us right now, PTing
Us right now...
Wtf am I talking about?
Although...
Uhhhhh
Resident Evil Extinction,
Is that- is that what they are called?
They are pretty interesting
I think- I think
I think....
It's- it's gonna be
Oh my god , What is happening?
I literally have the same camera....
This is fucking freaky as shit dude!!
You gotta see this i literally have the same fucking camera
Set up man...
Shockgun might be and everything
Oh my god, WTF?
Hey buddy!
Hey dude, that's an expensive camera...
Fucking hell. Do you know how much i paid for that?
Wtf are you doing mate?
Yeah...
This is weird...
Wtf
Dude that is...
A fucking bomb ass knife man...
So If that was the camera, why is my vision still like a camera...
And audio for that matter...
Am i robot?
this is like-
*reading german*
GOD DAMNIT!
Michael, it's your german account again!!
Oooo... i like the audio
Dont worry we'll change it-
Dont worry...
Oh hey...
I handed that...
Alright, now fucking-
We are not playing in Dutch
Alright...
Japanisch...
Do we have Swedish?
ENGLISCH
Englisch...
Ein, aus *Wtf are you talking pewds?*
Is this on or off?
How would I know?
I can't fucking.. Weiter?
Press Any Button
I did it...
I press the Any Button...
Wow we are playing, right away
Resident Evil 7 Teaser, Beginning Hour
Thank you.
*kiss*
For teasing us...
It probably spent a lot of money building this demo...
Sorry...
Hopefully it's a good one
*reading with german accent* get out of the house
hoooh
Ok...
This looks very interesing so far!!
I have that same couch.
Wtf is this?
Capcom you tryna troll me?
I shall dash them against the stones
Well...
That's what you do right?
Look they are playing MTV
*reads*
That was a lowkey burn everyone!
Looks like we need a fuse doesnt it?
Fuse is missing...
Who has fuses this big?
Marzia does...
Heyyyyy
Actually they are tiny,
I am just kidding,
I love her!
*kisses*
Marzia....
Please don't leave me
Now...
Where do we go?
We gotta find that fuse doe...
Let's look around a bit
Find some happy little clouds.
Alright...
Apparently I am a camera in my face
Hey look at that guy, I have the same glasses
WAT THE FUCK IS HAPPENING HERE CAPCOM
You tryna troll me...
I guess we'll go out and look for the...
The fuse...
Ohhh...
You press twice to open doors
Dude, this is fucking Scare Pewdiepie season 2 Man
look at this shit.
Hello?
Any...
Where did that other guy go?
Alright where is that fucking fuse man...
Trynna check out the controls, looks like we can croutch
Alright...
That might come in handy!
Surprisingly lack amount of zombies
A dummy finger...
Awesome!
Thanks!
Must have been Jacksepticeyes
Heyyy yooooo!
Jack is just my go to guy now...
I am so sorry...
It's nothing personal
It's that you are Irish
It's not your fault,
for being born Irish
Ya bitch
*kiss*
Love you though...
Alright let's check the fridge,
maybe there is a fuse in the fridge
They both start on "F"...
Soooooo...
OH MAY GAWD
That is...
No that anyone can open the fridge in a while...
It's...
They got some good maggot cake though...
That's pretty good, yeah...
Let's check the microwave ,yeah, i am sure they'll-
OH GOD WTF MAN
WTF IS THAT?
WHAT IS THAT?
EWWWWWWWWWWWWW
CLOSE IT
Thank you very much though,
That looks...
Not like I would like to have it!
The fuck is this?
It plays beautiful
*reads*
Just like my  *beatbox*
What was that
Is anyone out here?
Oh there is me, bumping into the table
Where am i?
What the fuck, everything is closed
God damn, this place suck
I'm glad you take the flash light ri- right away
It gets so old like,
"You have to find the flashlight"
Hello?
Oh.. God
OH GOD OH
WHAT DE FUUUCK
Oh
SHIT
I did not expect to see that
Hey we got Bolt Cutters every-
*scream*
JESUZ
Where do you come from?
Did i just squeal like a pig?
I literally did
*reads*
Why dont i use the Bolt Cutter?
Honestly tho
Well this is going great so far guys!
Uhhhhh
We found a pig,
sawed in half
Hope nooo vegeterians are watching...
Alright...
Soooo...
Wait what?
Okay.
You know what...
Color...
Color me interested so far
This is pretty cool!
The fuck this is not a key to get out?
Vhs tape?
But you don't even know what that is...
It's a nice cupboard, you know what?
I could paint this and make it nice again.
*laughs*
Just sayin...
Alright.....
Unnecessary piece of information for everyone
Alright , did we-
Yeah , yeah there was a tv in the bedroom
I KNOW!
I KNOW
You don't have to tel-
Oh god, there's upstairs as well
Jesus Christ , dude......
Let's start uhmmm
Let's start with the tv!
Oh my fucking dick!
Ohhhhh....
I dont think i should
ah
Fuck me in the ass
Hello?
Why do i always go to like the most sexual thing i can say when i get scared
It's fucking we-
That piano is gonna slam
I am gonna slam it now
Fuck you
There you go!
Bitch ass piano!
Alright let's put the vhjs tape here
Very interesting!
ohhh
*reads the text*
Rehearsal!
What???
What is this??
Oh fuck me
Jesus
What the fuck are you doing in here?
Oh we're playing the!
We are playing the vhs tape
Dude this is sooo coool!!!
Fuck you I am right here
My god this guy is literally me
*laughs*
Am I filming?
I think I am the camera guy
Yeah I am definitely the camera guy
That is brilliant
Please be back to me Resident Evil
Please be back
I love you
Yeah we are rolling,
uhhhh
Got the camera here ready, right here
Ohhhhh
Are we watching our own tape?
Gaps
That would make sense
Oh we saw them in the beginning
I've always wanted to do that!
One day i'll do that.....
Hello?
This is scary dude......
*laughs*
Pete is my hero
How fucking dare talk to me-
This is the same house!
Heyyyy
Guys what was that sound?
Why... Oh re-
*laughs*
It does look good!
Where the fuck-
Nooooo
Noooooo
Are you serious??
Oh my god
Thanks....
Thanks buddy
Just from what you said before i really feel honored
Alright camera- mc- Clancy
*Kapao*
Get all the shots!
Yeah
Dude this is gonna get like 6 million views in youtube mate
This is some Pewdiepie shit man
Should I- should I go?
Or you go?
You are the hero
You go
You are the star!
Yeah you go
Oh my goood
This is the room we came from!
Well clearly not in here man!
Oh fuck me man
What's with the fireplace?
Why are you looking there man?
What???
Noooooooo
Honestly....
Agree.....
But i don't think Andre is in there though...
I don't know why you insinuating he is there
You got a great ass though....
Let's keep this shot going
*reads*
Oh my looord
We are inside the walls of the haunted house
This is gonna be- this is gonna get so many fucking hits on youtube
This is gonna go viral
Viral Horror Video
Fuck you
Ohhh
*laughs*
I am enjoying this
This is a really cool g- demo
Alright i'll see ya
This is not what i expected
Uhmmm
It's like eh
Bandom shit
I am scared , can i go up now?
You coming down ya fucking pussy
OH MAH GAWD
NOooooooo
Ahhhhh
OHHHHH
OHHHHHH
ANDRE??
No
Nooooo
Oh boy!
Well we know what happened then......
Oh cool story
Oh wait there is uh-
*reads note*
Oh You against the stone, he changed -
Oh god plz
For the love of god
Well that would-
That's pretty much we got out of that
But now we know there is something here
I suppose we cant really ...
Do it twice cant we?
We can do it twice
Which opens up here but...
I don't really see a point going down here twice, You know what i mean?
There is the key
Okay
Thank you though
God i am legit scared right now!
This is fucking freaky man!
I am just gonna keep..
*gasp*
Oh...
My god.....
Do you think he pass or?
I think it was just like a ,
quick spook, i don't think he is actually there
We got the backdoor key now we just gotta get out!
Get out, get out!
I am just gonna run for it
Just gonna fucking run for it
That seems like the right thing to do right?
OH GOOOD
AHHH JAVLAR
FUUUUUCK
Go you son of a slow ass bitch, ass bitch
Oh goood!!
God jesus why??
*boom*
Freedom
Oh nooooo
Oh shit it was the dad!
Welcome to the-
What?
Just don't cut my dick off, when you know  you got the rope down...
You know what i mean?
Ahhh fuck!
Sorry about that lady!
Ohhhhh
ohhhhhhhhhhhhhh
ohhhhhhh
*reads*
WHAT, FUCK YOU
FUCK YOU MAN
You make me wait that long, how fucking dare you!
Tease me like that
Why do they always do that??
Tell me about the fucking game, a week before
And I'll be like hey cool, I can play
You can't make me wait that long!!
What the, fuck you
What a slap in the face with a ..... dick
God damn
Alright, let's ehh let's have a little chat
I am impressed, i think that looks pretty cool
It seems like a new direction for Resident Evil
Which i think they need to take
So what do you think , let me know
I am very interested
To be fair though i played demos before that are really cool
and then..
The full game is something completely different
But I like it how they kept it small, and i like how they tryna tell us the story
and i think eehh
yeah...
It's eh it's very interesing
I was not paid to play this demo or anything
i am giving you my honest opinion
And uhhh that's it, let me know what you think
Leave a like if you enjoyed it  and as always
Subscribe to become a bro today, I'll see you tomorrow bros I don't know why I did this intro so fast gotta end it's  over
*outro*
*pure blackness*Umm...Pewds...
WTF is going on?